marvel fans were given quite the
surprise on september 13th when the
first trailer for hawkeye dropped the
new mcu series marks the fourth
live-action show from disney plus
following one division the falcon and
the winter soldier and loki clint barton
is the only original avenger to be given
their own spin-off series likely meaning
a solo flick for the character won't be
coming the new trailer hints that
hawkeye will be a fun action-packed
watch set during christmas time in new
york city we get to see what clint has
been up to since the events of avengers
end game and it looks like things
haven't slowed down for him one bit
alongside jeremy renner as barton haley
steinfeld is at the trailer center
portraying kate bishop from the comics
vr farmiga is also briefly featured
playing kate's mother as with every
marvel trailer there are some small
details that can be easily missed here's
a quick rundown the first part of the
trailer shows clint enjoying a festive
meal with his children then we hear a
voiceover of clint saying i'm making up
for some lost time it's a pretty generic
turn of phrase bordering on cliche but
in this context it takes on added
meaning as an obvious allusion to the
blip in the opening scene of avengers
end game we see a barton family
afternoon disrupted by thanos to
heartbreaking results clint discovers
his entire family dusted by the snap
this is a huge turning point for the
character and as we've seen it will
inform the events of this series in the
wake of the snap hawkeye goes on a
vengeful murder spree until natasha
romanov brings him back to the avengers
clint's double life as a shield agent
and family man sets him apart from the
rest of the avengers we're excited to
see the tension between the two in this
upcoming series
i'll be home for christmas i promise
as the trailer opens fans get a glimpse
of new york's famous broadway theaters
although in this universe a new musical
is making waves rogers the musical
advertised with a photo of steve rogers
himself and staged at what appears to be
the real-life lunch fontan theater on
46th street in manhattan rodgers the
musical shows that cap's legacy remains
strong no matter who's currently donning
the suit and that nostalgia for steve
rogers is apparently at an all-time high
beyond that the brief look at the
musical itself looks pretty familiar to
anyone who loved one of disney plus
biggest 2020 releases hamilton
lin-manuel miranda's tony award-winning
musical about one of america's founding
fathers much like hamilton this
fictional musical seems to employ a
relatively sparse stage and features
every supporting character in steve's
life on stage at the same time for a
seemingly epic number including clint
who can be seen on the second level of
the stage wielding his signature bow and
arrow whether or not hawkeye features a
longer look at rogers the musical
remains to be seen but hamilton fans
might get an extra kick out of this
potential subplot which also brings to
mind spider-man turn off the dark the
pricey real-life broadway flop that
wasn't nearly as well received as the
fictional rogers the musical appears to
be although hawkeye's main arc in the
show revolves around the archer teaching
kate bishop the robes the duo will also
have their own street level threat to
deal with over the holidays fans
familiar with matt fraction's hawkeye
comic series will probably recognize the
red tracksuit wearing gangsters in the
first trailer they're clearly the
tracksuit draculas the thugs that clint
goes up against when he forcefully buys
the apartment building from one of its
members ivan baniones suggestive name
aside they're not vampires tracksuit
draculas is actually a pejorative term
derived by clint and bestowed upon the
goon squad they're just regular thugs
but they have ties to bigger figures in
the marvel underworld like wilson fisk
aka kingpin it looks like banyonus is
also in the trailer as we see a large
man with a mustache in a black tracksuit
jacket pointing a gun at clint while
he's tied to a chair because the
tracksuit draculas failed to defeat
clint in fractions run ivan banionis
hires an assassin called the clown to
take out the avenger irish star fra fee
took to twitter in december 2020 to
confirm that he's playing the clown in
the series although he doesn't show up
in the first trailer since marvel
studios and disney plus are clearly
leaning on the matt fraction hawkeye
comic series it's no surprise that the
trailer shows off one of the most
important characters from that run lucky
the pizza dog that's right true
believers hot guy's getting a canine
sidekick in fraction series lucky
belongs to the tracksuit mafia in a
particularly brutal scene the gangsters
beat lucky after he helps hawkeye in a
fight thankfully hakai rushes him to a
vet and the lovable pooch survives
albeit without his left eye you just
can't put a good dog down anyway the
trailer only provides a brief look at
lucky to assure fans that he's in the
disney plus series but this glimpse
confirms that he only has the one eye
it'll be interesting to see whether
hawkeye gives lucky his comic's accurate
backstory or if it'll adapt it slightly
to fit within the marvel cinematic
universe hopefully the writers really
take inspiration from fraction's run
where lucky's concerned and give him his
own mini adventure in one of the
episodes hawkeye number 11 follows lucky
as he tries to solve a murder yes that's
right he's a detective and a perfectly
capable one the issue doesn't feature
captions or word balloons instead it
shows how dogs perceive things via smell
it's an inventive comic book to say the
least and it'd be great if the show
honors it in some way and finally in a
blink and you'll miss it moment a
threatening face appears in the trailer
covered in red light this appears to be
alaqua cox's character maya lopez also
known as ekko in the marvel comics first
appearing in daredevil volume 2 number 9
ekko is a deaf native american from the
cheyenne nation she has an arsenal of
abilities including photogenic reflexes
acrobatics and is a master of martial
arts something important to know here is
that ekko also has ties to kingpin her
father once worked for the mobster who
vincent d'onofrio plays in the daredevil
netflix series for some time rumors
suggested the actor would be reprising
his role as the mob leader and without a
real villain present in the trailer it
looks like this might prove true echo
also appears in the moon knight and
secret invasion comic book story lines
meaning it's also possible the character
could appear in those disney plus series
as well
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
hawkeye are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]